الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن توقيع ممثلي الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع على اعلان
التزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان
ترحيب دولي ومحلي داخل السودان بتوقيع
اعلان جده ومطالب بالبناء عليه للتوصل
لوقف دائما للنار
تواصل القصف المتبادل بين الجهاد واسرائيل
وحديث عن ساعات حاسمه للتوصل الى هدنه
برعايه مصريه
[موسيقى]
طابع صباحكم واليكم نشره لاهم الانباء من
العربيه قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان الى مدينه جده جمعت
ممثلي القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع في مبادره لحل الازمه مضيفا
ان المحادثات التي تمت واعلان التزام
بحمايه المدنيين تاتي كخطوه اولى على ان
تتبعها خطوات اخرى معتبرا ان الاهم هو
التزام بما تم الاتفاق عليه مؤكدا ان
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ستعمل حتى يعود
الامن والاستقرار السودان وشعبه الشقيق
يسرني ان اهنئكم بما توصلتم اليه من اتفاق
كما اؤكد لكم حرص واهتمام خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز حفظه
الله وسمو سيدي ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان رئيس مجلس الوزراء
وحفظه الله على امن
واستقرار السودان
هذا الاتفاق الذي
جاء اليوم نتيجه لرغبتكم الصادقه في ان
يتجنب الشعب السوداني الشقيق الاثار
المترتبه على الصراع العسكري الدائره
حاليا
حيث سيسمح هذا الاتفاق بتامين المساعدات
الانسانيه الاساسيه للمتضررين
املا ان تساعد هذه الرغبه الصادقه التي
استشعرناها من وفديكما خلال المباحثات في
التوصل الى ما ينهي هذا الصراع بشكل تام
وافادت خارجيه السعوديه بان محادثات جدا
ستركز الان على التوصل الى اتفاق بشان وقف
فعال لاطلاق النار لمده تصل الى قرابه
عشره ايام وذلك لتسهيل هذه الانشطه وستشمل
اجراءات الامنيه اليه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار مدعومه من قبل الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه والمجتمع
الدولي اكدت خارجيه السعوديه انها تتطلع
لمشاركه المدنيين السودانيين والشركاء
الدوليين في المناقشات
الجيش السوداني هو قوه دعم السريعه كدافع
لاني جدا التزامهما بسياده السودان
والحفاظ على وحدته وسلامه اراضيه واتفق
الطرفان على السماح بمرور امنا للمدنيين
لمغادره مناطق الاعمال العدائيه الفعليه
واتخاذ جميع الاجراءات الممكنه لاجلاء
الجرحى والمرضى المدنيين والعسكريين كما
اكد طرفان نزاع في السودان التزامهما في
اعلان جده بجميع الاحتياطات لتجنب وتقليل
الاضرار التي تلحق بالمدنيين وعدم
استخدامهم دروعا بشريه الى جانب التزامهما
بحمايه العاملين في المجالات الانسانيه
وفي المجال الطبي وحمايه سيارات الاسعاف
وعدم استخدامها لاغراض عسكريه اكد اعلان
جده على ضروره الامتناع عن تجديد الاطفال
والامتناع عن الاحتجاز التعسفي للمدنيين
وفي سياق ردود الفعل رحبت الاليه الثلاثيه
التي تتكون من الامم المتحده والاتحاد
الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
المعنيه بالتنميه ايجاد رحبوا بتوقيع
اعلان التزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان
في جده الاليه الثلاثيه قالت ان الاعلان
خطوه اولى مهمه نحو التخفيف من المعاناه
الانسانيه وحمايه المدنيين في السودان
مطالبه بالانخراط في العمليه بشكل بناء
وبحسن نيه من اجل الوصول في نهايه المطاف
الى وقف دائما الاعمال العدائيه اما
داخليا رحب المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه
باعلان جده بوصفه خطوه اولى لاخراج
السودان من مازقه بدورها رحبت الجبهه
الثوريه السودانيه باعلان جده الذي قالت
انه يشكل قاعده لانطلاق نحو حل شامل
وثقت مبادره سودانيه بعنوان مفقود اختفاء
اكثر من 190 مدنيا منذ بدء المعارك بين
الجيش وقوه دعم السريع نتابع
اثر بعد عين لم يتبقى منهم الا صور
مفقود الحرب كارثه السودان الجديده
اكثر من 190 مفقودا حتى الان 54 مفقوده
خلال اسبوع واحد
اغلبهم مدنيون من الخرطوم وام درمان متوسط
اعمار معظمهم ما بين 20 و 35 عاما
12% منهم من كبار السن
[موسيقى]
عده بلاغات تتلقاها مبادره بعنوان مفقود
تسعى الى حصر اعدادهم يوميا وظروف
اختفائهم
مناشدات للبحث عنهم ميدانيا وبين جثث
مجهوله
اعداد المفقودين مرشحه للازدياد مع
استمرار المعارك
[موسيقى]
طلبه المصريون عائدون من السودان وطلب
سودانيون نازحون الى مصر الكل يعاني فقدان
الوثائق التي تثبت الموقف التعليم اثناء
الفرار من القتال الدائر في السودان ووسط
التسهيلات التي تحاول الحكومه المصريه
تقديمها للطلاب العائدين او تلك التي تقدم
للسودانيين من خلال مدارس السودانيه في
مصر تظهر مشكلات تهدد دراسات الطلاب من
الجانبين ونحمد وزير طالب مصري حصل طب في
جامعه افريقيا العالميه والعمر انه
الاسريه حزين جدا اللي بيحصل في السودان
حاليا وفرحتي برجوع لمصر ونجاتي انا
وزملائي
بجد الله يحفظك
بهذه المناشده يحاول احمد ابو زيد الحصول
على منحه لاستكمال دراسه الطب في مصر
والذي كان يدرسه في احدى الجامعات
السودانيه قبل عودته بعبوبه لمدينه كوموم
محافظه اسوان فرارا من القتال هناك هذا
الامر قد يتطلب تحركا اكبر مما جاء على
لسان وزير التعليم العالي في مصر لتيسير
اجراءات التحاق الطلاب المصريين العائدين
بالجامعات الاطار اللي بنشتغل عليه في
الجامعات الخاصه والاهليه بيتم
استيعابهم مباشره من خلال اضافه نسبه 10%
من هذه الجامعات لاستيعاب ولادنا مباشره
معظم الطلبه سواء كانوا من المصريين
العائدين او من السودانيين النازحين
يواجهون مشكله كبرى تتعلق بعدم قدرتهم على
ارفاق طلبات الالتحاق بالجامعات والمدارس
بالوثائق التي تثبت موقفهم التعليمي وذلك
لانهم خرجوا من السودان على عجاله من
امرهم بسبب الظروف الامنيه هناك هذه
المجموعه من السودانيين لديها كثير من
القصص عما يعانونه مع مراحل التعليم
المختلفه منا محسن بدات امتحاناتها في
السودان ونجت بعمرها عندما زادت وتيره
المعارك وانقطعت اسباب الحياه هنا
علينا امتحانات فاينل للسمستر وقبل ما
تنتهي كان لسه ما خلصنا يوم السبت اللي هو
يوم الضرب ذات وكان عندنا امتحان وما
قدرنا نكمل يعني من الجامعه لو قلت اطلع
من الجامعه
ما حيقدر لانه ما في ما في جامعه فاتحه ما
في اي مصلحه حكوميه فاتحه عشان انا اقدر
اسحب ورقه عشان اقدر اوسع ورقه عشان اقدر
اقدم جامعه تانيه عشان اقدر اطلع اقرا في
حته تانيه ابراهيم كان يذاكر للثانويه
العامه في مدرسه سودانيه على ارض مصر
والان تتضاربوا الاقوال بخصوص موعد
الامتحانات التي تقام عاده بالتنسيق مع
السفاره السودانيه ولكن المستقبل التعليمي
اقل من ان يشغل بال هذا الشاب الغيوري على
بلده شهر شهرين ما فرقت معنا لكن في ناس
فقدت بيوته
في السودان ماساويه يعني الحمد لله على كل
حال ربنا يصلح على البلد ان شاء الله
وحسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل في في كل من كان
سبب في الكلام الحاصل ده مستقبل الدارسين
في السودان في مراحل التعليم المختلفه
خاصه الثانويه العامه والتعليم الجامعي
مهدد بسبب الحرب الدائره ويحتاج لتدخلات
عاجله من الاطراف الفاعله لتجاوز هذه
الازمه تامر نصرت العربيه القاهره
[موسيقى]
عادت المفاوضات بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه بضغوط مصريه حيث ابلغت اسرائيل
القاهره موافقتها على العوده الى مفاضات
وقف اطلاق نار مصادر العربيه افادت بان
حركه الجهاد وافقت مبدئيا على وقف اطلاق
الصواريخ مقابل وقف اسرائيل لغاراتها على
غزه وبينما طالبت اسرائيل القاهره بالضبط
لازاله منصات الصواريخ من غزه قالت مصر ان
الامر يتوقف على تقديم اسرائيل بوادر حسن
النيه متمسكه بمطالبه حكومه نتنياهو بوقف
الاغتيالات مصادر العربيه ذكرت ايضا ان
العمل يجري للوصول الى هدنه خلال 48 ساعه
وان الامر متوقف على الوصول الى صيغه
تفاهم وان الساعات المقبله حاسمه
وقد تعرضت مجموعه من المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه لقصف صاروخيشنته الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه حيث استهدفت رشقات
من الصواريخ المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المنتشره في غلاف غزه اعقبها دوي سفارات
الانذار في المستوطنات المستهدفه في غلاف
القطاع كذلك وصلت رشقاته من الصواريخ الى
مستوطنات ريشون وسط اسرائيل وقال مراسل
العربيه ان رشقات صاروخيه جديده استهدفت
عسقلان وتسببت باصابه منازل في مستوطنه في
حين قلب مسؤول اسرائيلي لصحيفه دعوتا ان
جهود التوصل لهدنا فشلت وان اسرائيل سترد
على النار بالنار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اصيبت مركبه وزيره الاستيطان الاسرائيليه
اريد
صاروخ اطلق من قطاع غزه على مستوطنه وسقط
الصاروخ على بعد خمسين مترا من سياره
الوزير الاسرائيليه
اكد صحيفه التي نقلت عن مكتب وزير الدفاع
لتعليمات للجيش بتحضير سلسله من العمليات
الاضافيه ضد قطاع غزه والاستعداد اطلاقي
صواريخ على نطاق اوسع اما نتنياهو فاعلن
ان بلاده لا تزال في وسط العمليه العسكريه
سواء في الهجوم او الدفاع مشيرا الى ان
اسرائيل سترد على مطلقيه صواريخ هو من يحل
محلهم
في وقت سابق من صباح اليوم قمنا باغتيال
قائد مجموعه صواريخ الجهات في غزه والان
منذ فتره وجيزه اختل نائبه ايضا اي شخص
ياتي ليؤذينا لن يجني سوى الدم على راسه
هو ومن يحل محله نحن في منتصف المعركه في
الهجوم والدفاع وسنواصل التقدم لحمايه
سمائنا وحياه مواطننا
ان الشمس مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
اجتماع للمعارضه التركيه لمناقشه انسحاب
زعيمي حزب البلد محرم انجي من السباق
رئاسي
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت المعارضه التركيه
عن نيتها عقد اجتماع لمناقشه انسحاب زعيم
حزب البلد محرم انجي من السباق رئاسي جاء
ذلك على لسان زعيمه هي الحزب الجيد التركي
المعارض ميرال اكشنر التي وصفت الاسباب
التي دفعت انجل لسحب ترشحنا الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بالقذره للغايه وانه يجب على
تركيا التخلص من مثل هذه الاساليب التي
تطعن بالحياه الخاصه للاشخاص
في مقابله خاصه لقناه العربيه مع الزميل
طاهر بركه مع زعيم حزب الوطني اليساري
التركي اكد فيها بان اردوغان مضطر لان
يكون مع اسيا وصين وروسيا وايران والدول
العربيه وانه لا يملك سبيلا غير ذلك تركيا
تسير وراء قياده اردوغان ولن تخرج عن
مسارها ابدا واردوغان مضطر ان يكون مع
اسيا ومع الصين وروسيا وايران والدول
العربيه ولا سبيل امام اردوغان سوى هذا
يتطلع لو في الامه المعارض الذي يضم احزاب
الشعب
الجمهور سعاده وديمقراطي مدعوما بحزبين
ديمقراطيه والتقدم والمستقبل وجميعهم
يمثلون الطاوله السداسيه يتطلعون الى
الحاق اول هزيمه برئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في تاريخه السياسي
في حملته الدعائيه كمرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه يضع زعيم المعارضه صور رئيسي
بلديتي انقره واسطنبول الى جانب صورته لما
لهما من شعبيه في الشارع وهو ما يعيد نفس
السؤال الاول لدى جمهور المعارضه من الذي
كان ينبغي ان يترشح لمنافسه اردوغان زعيم
المعارضه ام احد رئيسي بلديتي انقره او
اسطنبول
قاده تحالف الامه او الطاوله السداسيه
قرروا ترشيح كمالك الجدار اوغلو بعد
اعتراض وانسحاب زعيمه حزب الخير ميرال
اكشنر مقابل عوده اكشنر مجددا للتحالف
تقرر تعيين رئيسي بلديه اسطنبول وانقره
كنواب للرئيس للاستفاده من شعبيتهما في
الحملات الانتخابيه وعمليات جذب الاصوات
المؤيده لهما
الى جانبك يشارك رئيس بلديه اسطنبول وانقر
في الحمله الانتخابيه وينحدر الرئيسان من
حزبنا كما تعلمون بهذا الفريق نرى ان
اسهمنا الانتخابيه تتجه نحو ايصال مرشحنا
السيد كليجدار اوغلو لمنصب الرئاسه
ويضم تحالف الامه احزابا يساريه وقوميه
واسلاميه تساندها احزاب شق مؤسسوها عن حزب
العداله والتنميه هذه القوى السياسيه
اجتمعت كلها على خصومه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان لذا كان البرنامج الانتخابي لهم
يتمثل في الغاء كل ما جاء به اردوغان
كالغاء النظام الرئاسي والعوده الى النظام
البرلماني المعزز والغاء العديد من
الهيئات والمؤسسات التي انشاها اردوغان
ولم يهمل قاده التحالف القضيه الاساسيه
التي تفقد خصمهم رصيده في الشارع الا وهي
التضخم والوضع الاقتصادي المتازم خلال
السنوات الماضيه قمنا باعداد وثيقه تتالف
من 2300 ماده وايضا لدينا وثيقه اعاده
تطبيق النظام البرلماني عبر اجراء تعديلات
دستوريه هذه الوثائق ستتضمن عمليه التغيير
المرجوه رغم ذلك ارى انه من الطبيعي ان
تطرا خلافات بين الفينه والاخرى داخل
تحالف سياسي يضم سته احزاب سياسيه تختلف
فكريا كثير من معارضي هذا التحالف يراهنون
على هشاشه العلاقه بين الاحزاب المنضويه
فيه ويؤكدون ان ازمه اختيار مرشح مشترك
تمثل تجربه اولى لتلك الاحزاب ستعقبها
تجارب واختبارات اخرى في حال وصلت
المعارضه الى السلطه اما مؤيد التحالف
فيؤكدون ان الخلافه لا يفسد ود السياسه
لكن الجميع يتفق ان قاده التحالف ارتبط
مصيرهم جميعا بهذه الانتخابات فاما نصر
يخلدهم في صفحات السياسه التركيه او خروج
من المشهد السياسي ومن الباب الضيق زيدان
زنكلو العربيه اسطنبول
شكك قائد مجموعه فاجنر يفغيني في كلام
الرئيس الاوكراني
عن ان الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لن ينطلق
قريبا واعتبر زعيم مجموعه فاجنير ان
الوحدات الاوكرانيه بدات بالفعل هجومها
المضاد لسيما في محيطي بخمط واطرافها
بالنسبه للهجوم المضاد يخادع الهجوم
المضاد يمضي بسرعه وعلى قدم وساق تهاجم
وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني محور باخموت
وللاسف هم ينجحون بذلك كما ذكرت مرات عده
فان خطه القوات الاوكرانيه تتمحور في
خنقنا نحن نحاول خنقهم وهم يحاولون كذلك
هم يحتاجون اولا الى التخلص من عناصر
فاجنر في محور باخموت ثم التوجه بكامل
الامكانيات الى
ذلك فان الهجوم الاوكرانيه بدا لقد حصلوا
بالفعل على المعدات العسكريه اللازمه وعلى
التدريب اللازم عناصر فاجنر تواصل مهامها
القتاليه رغم عدم وجود الذخائر والدعم
الذي وعدت به وزاره الدفاع
ان بردا عسكريا مناسب على تعهد المملكه
المتحده بتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ المتطوره
وتوعد على لسان الناطق باسمه ديمتري
بريسكوفا برد مناسب من الجيش الروسي وذلك
بعد ان اكد وزير الدفاع بريطاني بانس منح
بلاده تلك الهبه تحضيرا لحضور اوكرانيا
ولهجومها المضاد اليكم قدرات هذا الصاروخ
[تصفيق]
البريطاني اكثر سلاحا متقدما تتلقاه
اوكرانيا منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه هو صاروخ كروز بعيد المدى طورته
المملكه المتحده وفرنسا بشكل مشترك يزيد
مداه عن 250 كيلومترا وهي مسافه اقل بقليل
من مدى انظمه الصواريخ ارض ارض التكتيكيه
الامريكيه السنه التي يبلغ مداها 297
كيلومترا والتي كان زيلنسكي قد طالب بها
سابقا
يمكن اطلاق صاروخ ستورم شادو من الارض او
باستخدام الطائرات بل ويمكن تركيبه على
طائرات سوفيتيه الصنع التي تستخدمها
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه قبل الوصول
لهدفه وعبر تقنيه حديثه تعمل باشقه تحت
الحمراء ينخفض ستورم شادو تحت الارتفاعات
المعروفه لتجنب اكتشافه من قبل الرادارات
يستطيع الصاروخ الوصول الى جميع الاقاليم
الاوكرانيه التي احتلتها روسيا بما في ذلك
شبه جزيره القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام
وزير الدفاع البريطاني وخلال تقديم هذه
الصواريخ الاوكرانيا اكد انها ستبدل وقائع
المعركه خصوصا انها تعطي اوكرانيا القدره
على ضرب مواقع ابعد بمائه 171 كيلو مترا
مما توفره لها انظمه صواريخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه التي تمتلكها بالفعل
بهدفي رص المهاجرين الذين يعبرون اليها من
ايطاليا اعلنت فرنسا بدات تسهيل طائرات من
دون طيار وزياده عدد الدوريات الحدوديه مع
ايطاليا ياتي هذا القرار على اثري ازمه
دبلوماسيه اندلعت بين البلدين وافر
اتهامات متبادله على خلفيه تزايد اعداد
المهاجرين الذين يصلون الى اوروبا من
سواحل تونس وليبيا مهاجرون من دول غرب
افريقيا تقطعت بهم السبل هنا في مدينه
فانتيميليا على الحدود الفرنسيه الايطاليه
وما زاد من معاناتهم انهم وقعوا ضحايا
ازمه دبلوماسيه اندلعت بين روما وباريس
على خلفيه ملف الهجره والمهاجرين غير
النظاميين هنا يبدا المهاجرون يومهم
يغتسلون ويستحمون بمياه النهر البارده
وعلى ضفتيه اقاموا عالما موازيا بعيدا عن
مجتمع معاد لهم وينظر اليهم بازدراء
احيانا والله ياهو قاعدين تهت الكوبري
ونغسل من ميل بارده دي
وما في اكل زي الناس وبطاطين ما في ما في
فرشه زي الناس منهم في الوطن والكلام
معاناه بعض المهاجرين هنا مركبه فمن بينهم
تشاديون مثل ناصر الذي ولد في السودان
واقام فيه لكنه تركه بعد الازمه التي
اندلعت واصبح غير قادر على العوده ما نقدر
نرجع السودان مشاكل قبليه ومشاكل سياسيه
كل شيء هنا
منذ فتره اسبوعين وما نقدر نضع فرنسا
يرجعوك من القطار اعداد المهاجرين في
ايطاليا اليوم هي اربعه اضعاف ما كانت
عليه السنه الماضيه بحسب الحكومه وضع
سيدفع روما الى خوض مفاوضات خلال الاسابيع
المقبله مع القاده السياسيين في تونس
وليبيا و خلالها ستقترح ايطاليا مساعدات
اقتصاديه ولوجستيه على البلدين مقابل
تشديد مكافحتهما للهجره من سواحلهما
لكن الى ذلك الحين لن تخلو سكه القطار هذه
من المهاجرين فصعوبه التضاريس الجبليه بين
ايطاليا وفرنسا جعلت احلام هؤلاء معلقه
بقطارات تعبر الى الجانب الفرنسي على امل
ان يبطئ احدها فيتسللون اليه وتكتب لهم
حياه جديده في فرنسا من مدينه فانت ميليا
الايطاليه فادي الدهوك العربيه
في نهايه النشره لم يبقى الا نذكر
بالعناوين
الخارجيه السعوديه تعلن توقيع ممثل الجيش
السوداني وقوه دعم السريع على اعلان
التزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان
ترحيب دولي ومحلي داخل السودان بتوقيع
اعلان جده ومطالب بالبناء عليه للتوصل
لوقف دائما للنار
تواصل القصف المتبادل بين الجهاد واسرائيل
وحديث عن ساعات حاسمه للتوصل الى هدنه
برعايه مصريه
ولمتابعه المزيد من الملفات والاخبار
والتحليلات تزور موقعنا العربيه
ونشره جديده بعد دقائق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات